Rhett: Due to a large influx of fake weapons, we had to redo this beautiful weapon rack wall that we've had.
It's gonna go across down here.
We're gonna do a second rack across here.
And then we're gonna save this piece of board and shift it up and over for some of the other items.
It's gonna fit a whole lot more of 'em.
*weapon breaks*
Wren: *Pffffff*
Don't put that in the edit!
Now I'm pulling incredibly large nails, that have been hammered over like crazy,
back out of these boards because we recycle.
Cmike: Oh no!
Wren, help!
Wren: Oh, I'm coming.
Always here to clean up your mess, Carmichael!
So, no idea what's in this. Let's find out.
I don't-
Oh my god! Are you serious?!
This is one of those portable gaming sets, you put your console in here.
Was this just like sitting in here?!
Cmike: There's another one right there.
I assume this will work just fine with a PS4 or something.
Is there like a battery or do you have to plug it into power?
If I were to ask Niko about it he'd probably be like
"Oh yeah. Yeah, we've had that."
Do you know- do you know what these are?
Niko: Yeah they're suitcases that are supposed to fit an Xbox and they come with a screen inside.
Wren: How long have we had these?
Niko: They've been upstairs for years.
I don't know.
It turns out, you know, we hook our Xboxes up to TVs and don't use them for mobile gaming.
Wren: That's what phones are for.
Okay, yeah so you do plug this into power.
Niko: Yeah it needs to be plugged in so it's kinda useless.
It does have a cool little HDMI cable, though.
Wren: This is probably more useful than anything else in this.
Treasure, yeah, found it.